citizens of the reject Nation we are here for the
Doctor Who 60th anniversary special part thr rest
today so excited two things that I got to tell
you are very important one t in the weather but
I am jacked up bunch of you Fu right now two Is
that real rejects have launched a brand new shirt
today just finished it a couple of days ago I've
been working on this for a while take a look at
his doctor who inspired we call this the wibbly
wobbly timy wiy the doctor's lexicon tshirt it is
the T is full of a bunch of Doctor Who quotes
graffiti and all that glorious work my sister
actually developed this one and it's been a shirt
that I've been wanting the real rejects to have
for quite some time now I figured why not launch
it now since the specials are airing it's one
of the best ways to support the channel we also
got a bunch of other t-shirts but go ahead Hans
buy this shirt because it'll be in the mail for
us next week can't wait to be wearing it anyway
guys leave a like on this video be very much
appreciated also big thank you to Eric over at
nerdc for editing now these reaction highlights
for us for Doctor Who he's also one of the main
people in charge of the website passion fruit
which goes to help support other reaction channels
I've done an interview there myself as well as
many other reactors fullly watch s with your
own copy of Doctor Who available for our super
sex rejects over at our patreon page over there
you can catch fulling threat and watch along
but we also cover several shows exclusiv over
there with highlights and watch alongs included
we cover most of our Doctor Who uh reactions
over there as well John are you okay you good
I'm traumatized already J do this let's get to
it going to the
Past Wonder Emporium yeah
I was going to say where's
mum there he is behold we have
everything everything you could
be goant and we have dolls yeah we have
the teddy bears and the Harvey hor who
does not want a harvey hor and to
go clip I want a hobby hor to go
clippity Bill fa poor stooky Su and the
poor stooky babies you would leave them
without Papa cruel man you apologize for the
rain you must be used to sunnier climbs oh
what does that mean buddy chelam being a German
racist I hope the kitties enjoy him he's having
a lot of fun with the other the German isms may
God go with us there but by the grace of God go
I the horse of Television oo
I did it Charlie I did it the
Nickelodeon that is a jump scare
that we we chaps about to change the
world I like this guy's
Spirit big titles Russo Brothers text Wasteland
doctor again man this season been throw down
for practical effects and stunts what are
you doing I can't drive okay so which mean
I'm paid for this road and I will do with
it what I like you'll get yourself my life
not yours there is uh oh everyone started
thinking their right including me well not
me what I've always been right that's right
you have die on that Hill buddy oh now he's
French the doctor where you are
unit get him to safety I want my
Grandad safe all right you got that
yes ma'am we'll keep your family
safe yeah protect wil at all [Music]
costs he does not remember the toy
maker that's a great shot I didn't even
know it's the Tardis a later yeah D they
got themselves an Avengers Tower Charlie you
can't be serious I'm Kate Lethbridge Stewart
and don't call me Shirley your father working
night and day to keep unit secret and look at
you now out and proud in defending the earth
oh never mind serious hug robots and insects
and yetis and clones but what do we do this
time doctor how do we fight the human race
all those Easter eggs listed jeez getting down a
business cuz I'm going to need all the statistic
oh no way hey oh that is the best news Melanie
hello Legacy character Legacy character let's
go basically every single human being
thinks they're right and won't be told
otherwise oh no what do I care why should I
care about you no change there then hey hey
watch the political politicians are
right their public servants that's
my brain activity seems normal orbe
it slightly heightened that's Kate's
brain oh my God she's racist hello
how are you fine busy day yeah
he wants to know music is overpowering
right and I think it's highly relevant
that the person demanding information for me is
an alien I think she makes a fair point no yeah
I think she's right in that chair I've seen
you walk I've seen you walking don't deny it
you bigot it's about time you heard the truth
activate deactivate Karen mode so the bracelet
is a metaphor for the vaccine it's the fac OD
we put on ourselves to mask our prejudices I'm
so sorry absolutely no need this happens
every time you demonstrate that I'm used
to it I'm wearing a zedex just in case but I've
been fine well no more opinionated than you oh
Tardis energy or something long-term travel
in the tarus P you out of sink yeah see they
are using this to control us and monitor us
and microwave our brains I am anti- Zex oh
my God oh my God it is a metaphor is Max
oh no but coat is clean we've checked and
double checks it's not like the old Archangel
Network there's nothing hiding in that signal
Archangel clap clap for reference references
put one on the board maybe it's music it's
tabs oh it's a musical palindrome keg Jak
for arpeggio everyone knows arpeggio there's
a basic tune I don't even know what arpeggio
means so familiar it's like has been buried
in my head for years have you ever taken a
piano lesson oh it's you start of Television
to laugh stooky Bill the first face to
ever appear on television put there by
John logy bed himself is that accurate
to history I don't know I never heard
these names before into television itself
and every picture ever since every single
one everyone and everywhere he's inside of all
two days this is the very first existence of
Television television is brainwashing us the
idiot box but something on that scale over so
many years who could do that puppet is just
a puppet we're looking for the Puppeteer the
maker of the puppet toy the human race might
be clever and bright and Brilliant it's also
Savage and venal and Relentless yeah the lies
the righteousness that's human that's you that's
who you are and it's all cuz of the TV using
your intelligence to be stupid o I love that
bar yeah something else is using your worst
attributes playing with me a game like toys
oh who could do such a thing I fed the coac
fake coordinates so it's coming into UK orbit
within ranging three minutes you're brilliant
kill her hi why does he give them names she
just call you like number five I'm not even
going bother to learn your name there'll be
another one of you next season time to go
home I lift office zingo and came back to
Earth I've got nothing a my family are all gone
remember yeah doctor do you remember but then
Kate offered me a job and here I am I'd love
how Kate offers the old companions jobs yeah
you should think about joining unit how much per
year 60,000 Jesus 120 plus 5 weeks holiday done
damn dude Jesus T The Negotiator I just keep
thinking all this time you've never mentioned
her doesn't mention anything I'm a billion years
old I talk about everyone I'd ever met we'd still
be in the Tet yapping you'll never talk about
Donna I saw you doctor I got a glimpse inside
your mind yeah uhhuh it's like you're staggering
maybe that's why your old face came back you're
wearing yourself out oh I forgot about that
whole likeo yeah yeah this is is peculiar isn't
it the ball is the first game ever being invented
and now everybody loves the Bor love balls don't
not go back to the tus go back to the Tardis you
never tell me to do that oh but he is recognizing
me o are you not get pleased a doctor after so
many years who is he not the master oh damn we
bringing back oh [__] actually doing flashbacks
did they color that in it looked like it if B was
the very first game what was the second hide
and seek that came after the ball oh good oh
how fun no no no no no no don't now you're in
a Pac-Man hallway we've stepped ins his domain
and it's governed by the rules of play yes
like messing with Mysterio this is impossible
how does it exist that's what unravels me it's
an illusion when I was young I was so sure of
myself I met a terrible M when I was young
but I look so old Tardis fall into another
realm a hollow beneath the under Universe a
hollow Earth oh where science is a game and
all of us are toys that sounds awesome I beat
the to maker I won his game but now he's here
I I think it's all because of me it's got to be
I cast that sword at the edge of the Universe I
played a game and let him in oh damn Elemental
force with the power of a g he's driven the
human race mad with a puppet direct consequences
from the last episode Sonic and tus and Time Lord
take that away what am I now just a lost child
I don't know if I can save your life this time
maybe I'll save you a I hope so Donna hold on
I'll lose next time no doesn't work like that
you're the doctor man because my dad used to
say dice don't know what the dice did last time
that's true games don't have a memory dice don't
know what the dice did last time that's that's a
clever that was really smart of you let's
just iMed it's okay you got to keep the
game progressing you got to make a choiceed
any choice left out of behind I've got you
what is it what happened I bought a toy and
I paid the price ready up why is he wrapped
in that paper does he have like a dummy body
back to the show he do think so yeah that's
cool oh cool yeah got some strings to hold me
up cool creepy St that's pretty neat man I love
that demented jigsaw yeah do
you like my puppets doctor
it's like reprising the roll from The Matrix W yes
is someone's going to make merch out of the doctor
dummy oh hell
yes I'm s Su they took my bill away I'm on
him every day bars now the stooky babies
weep stooky bobies can sleep they miss their
kiss good night the and Endless Night stooky
impossible took your bobies kill those babies
kill the puppies seen the cry and now it's
time to die my name's Donna now I think you're
G bars Donna playing the game out of that on the
spot God I'm going to miss
this show is just beginning worldwide premere this
is so whims musical let me tell you what happened
when the doctor he was leaving you he met an a
friend called Amy P oh whoa you're going to learn
about all the companions Amy P was touched by
the V ping anel she died what she died of old age
that's not how it happened man that's all right
then CLA CLA you skipped Rory she was killed by
a bird Raven she still survives in her last second
of life well that's all right then Bill not stooky
bill but lady Bill these are just feature action
figures was killed by the cber men a they do all
die her Consciousness survives oh well that's
all right then no one walks out just happily
ever after def whoa whoa whoa Jody Whitaker had
like 14 Companions deflux was killing everything
more or less I challenge you to a game now he
mad I came to this universe with such delight
and I played them all doctor NE Patrick the
master was dying and begged for his life with
one final game and when he lost I sealed him for
all eternity inside my gold too [Laughter] those
teeth oh there face the one who Waits who weird in
I saw it hiding and I ran what do you mean that's
someone else's game no it's coming back are we
teasing some future episode I made every opinion
Supreme that's the game of the 21st century sure
and they type and they cancel cancel C you choose
I'll go first she no sh that's the one thing you
won't do the only rules the toy maker follows
are the rules of the game they bind his entire
existence but does he create the rules of the game
yeah King's High I'm the king I won the
game many years ago you won today which
leaves us equal two players are bound by
one inviable rule best two out of three
best of three best of three then let's
make it 2023 that's harder I'm already
running oh my God I wish we could just check
back in with these two every you know 5 10
years woo goodbye goodbye grimald play wa that
was great yeah that was amazing something entered
this world in 1925 I don't know how and I warn
you this thing can get from 1925 to now like
stepping through a door an elemental Force
beyond the rules of the universe the Parker
Brothers could you turn that off please
who is that no one turns the Spice Girls
off oh yes get off all of them get the
the German one the French one the British
one SP up be
life oh oh my god well and that's
how that companion died no don't
yeah whoa everything everywhere
all at Doctor Who punch line oh
my God it's like Thanos with a
reality Stone boom and American
Beauty up your life people of the
world spice up your life a have
[Laughter] demented I need more flowers
in my gun yes how does he do that if I
told you he manipulates atoms with a power of
thought would you believe it is that what he
does oh my God he's got the galvanic
beam there's a game how I am liking
this boang boom he's like Riddler and Joker
combined I don't understand why you're so small
what don't call me that you know full well this
is merely a face concealing a vastness that will
never cease because you're good and you're bad are
nothing to me good or bad is subjective you know
full well that I've had many faces containing
something far more but why this face so come
with me come with me now we can take your games
back to the Stars we can play across the cosmos
forever we can be Celestial the time lord and the
toy maker infinite games infinite PR that would be
something special yeah and yet I have fallen
in love with Humanity sure you have Shackled
to their bedrooms with their joysticks and their
buttons suffer the little children out of bricks
falling upon other bricks you are exceptional
the dating and ghosting the deceit and the
control you make me dizzy the dark complexity
of the humans no fight is with me one more
yo what is in a galvanic beam I played the
second game with this doctor is this going
to lead to the Regeneration play the third
game with the next Doctor what a transition
damn are we doing it now he's not dying
alone is this right now I guess sudden
I'm going to be with it so am I and my ax
it's not dying I know but you're going to
be someone else soak up some of that time
lord juice it doesn't matter who cuz every
single one of you is fantastic e used to say
that fantastic here we go again oh no I'm not
ready how long how long
I don't think it's going to
happen they're messing with
[Music] us pull pull my finger
you what do you mean just pull
is he like a party popper now
feels different this time can he
stretch what who what what is it like a binary
situation I guess maybe or a non-binary there
going to be two doctors a quinary y man I'm you
I'm me what a way to introduce no I'm me really
really me completely me don't just s push oh
this is push changing up the way we go about
Doctor Who for sure new regeneration rules he's
got pants on he in his ties it's good someone
tell me what the hell is going on here how did
that happen by generation I have by generated
by generation is supposed to be a myth but by
generation get the Myth Busters here I think
you're beautiful still beautiful yeah did you
come in a range of colors yes you I could play
this for a hundred years I'll have vast Meadows of
doct and I'll never get bored because I challenge
you to a game oh yeah I'm the doctor and I'm the
doctor and according to the rules you can't say
no it's your game and you did this this is so so
bizarre name your challenge doctor the first game
ever the ball yes catch it's a simple game really
but I think if you drop it you lose don't drop it
nice do it like a hacky sack I really wonder
how people are going to respond to this rule
yeah yeah is hi I'm so sorry interesting not
bad [Music] alop you know this is a pretty
epic game of catch one might even call it
[Music] Legend oh no to do best to four out of
five and my prize toy maker is to banish you
from existence forever what it's not can't this
is just like his rule in The Matrix is he making
him a flat Stanley my Legions are coming Legions
of Legions Legion we did it but how many died
down there that's not your fault you're just Ken
yeah a it's okay masculine tenderness I like it
a literally get to embrace
yourself oh the master will return who just
grabbed it who hand is that who just grabbed
it you're thin as a pin love you've been
running on fumes that's what I keep saying
oh so we're like starting a new with this guy
yeah that doctor that first met the toy maker
never ever stopped that very first put on trial
exiled key to time all the devastation of lopis
all those classic episodes River Song River Song
Sarah Jane has gone can you believe that for a
second but her Chronicles I loved her end Rose
but the time wor Pandora car mavic Chen we're
saying goodbye to a whole era you're fine I'm
fine because you fixed yourself we time Lords
were doing rehab out of order o he's saying you
need to stop you need to take a CH her relax cuz
you know what I did I lived day after day after
day would drive me mad yeah it does us all it
does the one Adventure you've never had whoa
you changed your face a cuz we're in love know
cuz she can show him the path to chilling out a
finally come to [Music] dinner I'm still having
a hard time wrapping my head around this whole
by generation thing but I could never let the
Tardis go what if what if oh oh what do you
got in some pants hey watch this watch this
watch watch watch watch stand back stand back
wish me luck what for we won the game you get
a prize honey here is mine oh what is happening
what is happening I cannot wrap my head around
this oh my God everybody gets a series oh look
hey a ramp woke oh he's got the Jukebox it's
nothing but Leonard Skinner tunes on there it's
all Freebird now you two if you don't mind there
is a great big universe out there calling and
I've got to get going so off your pop old man
he's younger cuz you came after him so you're the
older doctor okay kid old white guy always wins
a how
cool Charlie don't suppose you've seen this
before don't see it off myself and don't call me
surely good luck good luck and the one with
the flowers is a chicken I still feel like
we're going to be following the doctor yeah
I know I mean tenant you know with my best
friend my brother-in-law the evil stepmother
oh I have barely begun I'm mad Auntie Mel mad
aren't you Mel and Grandpa wolf and Granddad
where is he oh he's off shooting moles there
he is now W lives funny thing is I fought
all those battles for all those years and
now I know what for to retire I've never
been so happy in my life oh [Music] buddy
what do we got toss a coin in that jukebox
so interesting we thought Timeless child
CH up the Lord know like d like I'm going to
up y'all yeah we're not resetting [__] all
right destination Christmas that's to wrap
your goddamn head around that's for sure all
righty well I've got I've got a lot of Praise
okay and I've got a lot of questions sure that
might lead to criticisms depending on the answers
specifically John gives me wow you hate Doctor Who
no no no not at all I actually quite enjoyed the
hell out of this episode my criticisms will be
mild there more concerns depending on the answers
John gives me I have so many answers G this is
why we need an ending explained yes I honestly
I mean for something like this yeah it is sort
of like what are the rules exactly I could use it
I could use it let's unpack our feelings as we go
um before we go into any of that just another
reminder that one of the best ways to support
the channel is reject naations shop.com where
you can get yourself some RR apparel and we got
shirts like chop protection services for Pedro
Pascal baby grou space babies of the Galaxy but
of course we got our recently launched Doctor Who
tshirt yeah baby Alon bunch of other quotes decked
out on the Tardis also if you're listening this on
Apple and Spotify please rate this video now John
I'm John you're John uh here's what I loved here's
what I loved I love The Madness of this episode I
thought it was a lot of fun I think these specials
I quite enjoyed all of them my favorite would
still probably be wild blue y uh and this would be
uh it would go 2 3 1 yeah for me I think I agree
I like them all but I like them in that order I
like them in that order specifically um but I I
loved how this had a little bit of that absurdest
horror I thought Neil Patrick Harris was a lot of
fun I thought I'd be distracted that it was Neil
Patrick Harris the whole time just like in The
Matrix movie sure where I was really distracted
I don't remember what his character was it wasn't
the architect it was something else the analyst
yeah I always I don't know why I really really
got a gripes with with him in that movie for some
reason just I was so distracted that it was Neil
Patrick Harris the entire time but anyway that's
beside the point I really I believed him as the
character of the toy maker here and I I thought
he had so much fun with the different accents that
he was doing like he he just he brought his stage
presence to life here I thought and um I I thought
it was a great delight and and a wonderful foil
for the doctor oh yeah and in every account and in
terms of like what they did with the by Generation
Um there were so many moments that I thought were
very tender and touching you know like what
what's his name 15th doctor uh shti gatwa
yeah okay it's GNA be a while before I call him
that let's call let's call 15 for a while 15 all
right Dr g i I will I'll remember it by next
week all right you got this so 15th doctor
uh when like 15th hugged 14 I thought that was a
really sweet moment because the only one who could
really understand the pain would be 15 um 14 being
able to say there there things contextually that
uh even outside of my questions that I really love
like you know you had uh one through eight doctor
show cancelled or ended or whatever right I a
prolonged break took a prolonged break there's
a movie in between and some other stories they
told and then they come back with nine yeah and
now they've ended this era from 9 to 14 they've
ended that era essentially the story at least
because they're going to start over with 15 yes
you know so I I love how we got to have certain
goodbyes you know tenant got Rose you know what
I just realized they never mentioned Martha and
all that like companion talk yeah that's they
mentioned Rose they mentioned bill they mention
Amy mentioned Rose Bill Amy and uh they didn't
mention any of Whitaker's no Whitaker had like
12 companions yeah and I guess for the most
part they're they're mostly fine I guess so
that's a little different like I guess of all the
companions they they don't have the the harshest
lives to get back to still did not mention any
of them sure yeah um and I'm surprised that they
would Overlook Martha cuz she was a she was a good
one what happened with her sh end up with Mickey
or some [__] I for like she she does something
it doesn't matter yeah um so I I loved I loved
uh 15's um performance you know you're going to
get both in this one episode yeah and you really
got to distinguish them and I and I I enjoyed
his introductory performance quite a bit H and
he takes command of the screen felt comfortable
and I loved that tenant was really sharing the
screen with him and it was interesting because a
lot of times when you get you know your collabs
with the doctors it's be you've been take take
the other special when you had Smith and tenant
yeah you know you've been hanging out with Smith
for a while then tenant comes back and it's the
nostalgic crossover element of hey look at these
two crossing over together and this is completely
different where I am literally going to be sharing
the screen with you whilst introducing you to
the world it's a completely different gamble yeah
yeah that's a very hard thing I and I for Imagine
what's his name 15 Chuy gatwa chuti gatwa yeah
chuty we could start there I think yeah it's it's
yeah we could start with Chuy chy the last name
okay godwa godwa chuty the last name is the easy
part it's it's chuty sounds way easier to me say
well it's when you look at it it's spelled ncuti
so it's for americ don't throw that in my bra John
don't throw that in my name chti chy got one I can
remember chy cuz I I imagine it spell totally
different sure chti phonetic phonetics excuse
me guys I'm a little under the weather stomach
is also killing me I got this like big stomach
pain bloat happening at the same time you were
in the worst shape imaginable but Doctor Who I'm
willing to keep going still bringing the joy I got
to do this so chti um uh yeah everything about his
performance was great and and and I think that for
him to be introduced here uh I I'm like yeah I'm
looking forward to seeing what he does there was
so much I really loved about it what do you think
John before I get to my questions I enjoyed this
verily I enjoyed this quite a bit this has uh I
think it's One Last Thing Before I Forget before
I just before I just let myself settle with my
little symptoms for a while please I'm sorry John
get it out get it out we discussed this prior I so
okay the the how like Rose had a tragic ending
in some ways right initially yeah but then she
got to be off with Tennant yeah yeah yeah and
and Donna had tragedy Beall her in in a lot of
ways and there was a a Darkness to her you know if
she remembers she'll die meta crisis all that yeah
but she's able to they're able to have this like
sweet tenderness like who knows how long 14 would
be there but this is the exact antithesis to the
kind of life that the doctor never thought he'd
be able to live yeah and now he gets to have the
opportunity to live that and I think that is so so
sweet and unexpected and and a big part of why I
like the choice of what they did yeah yeah you get
the sense he actually gets to rest for the first
time the doctor rests and now um as you should
now I'll let you uh talk for a little bit before
before we get to fix stuff no I I I've like I said
and we've touched on really enjoyed all three of
these specials and it's been such a lovely thing
to have David Tennant and kathern Tate back
especially and all of our sort of surrounding
players and unit and things like that both new and
old uh and yeah this was an episode that certainly
I think they did a nice kind of Trio here that's
proportionate in that yeah you have uh the first
episode uh you know which is very much kind of
doing uh I don't know I it felt kind of like a
synthesis of the Whitaker reintroduction but going
back to the tone of the tenant era especially um
and yeah you're you're you know kind of dealing
with a terrestrial thing here at home then in the
second one you're dealing with an isolated very
sci-fi thing out in the future and then these two
episodes the middle and the last one both go into
the past for certain little historical details uh
which I thought was really nice and apparently uh
uh I think his name was John loie be is a real guy
that whole thing with the TV is you know based
on actual History stooky Bill uh is a real you
know puppet from history I love when they do that
stuff and yeah this episode had especially um a
lot of just the the Aesthetics that appeal to me
directly of like you pointed out the sort of like
trippy gothic stuff they're doing when they're in
like the infinite Scooby-Doo hallway and you've
got the demented mannequin uh you ventriloquist
dummy dolls and uh and yeah you've got these like
circus elements and stuff like that I I really
enjoyed the Whimsy and the and the madness of
the toy maker and his presence here and yeah
I think that NPH you know it can go either way
because I'm a fan I enjoy him but yeah it depends
on what the thing is and there are certain things
you watch where you're like yeah he's perfect
for this and it and he Blends in really nicely
with everything around and then there are some
things like I get your point with the Matrix
where it is like I'm kind of aware of that I'm
watching you specifically and I get that maybe
that's part of the point um but I think that
plays better here because yeah like you know
you're watching NPA Ag and he is big but I liked
that he clearly you know brought all of his you
know utmost Showmanship and flamboyant and I like
the whole thing with the accents going back from
the geram to you know the French a little bit I I
don't know much about the original toy maker other
than learning that it was Michael Goff who's you
know a prolific British actor was Alfred and the
Tim Burton Batman and stuff that's who that was
and that character was like a a kind of an Asian
stereo typ so they you know adjusted it Fu man
cheu kind of yeah that would have been way better
yeah we just have Neil Patrick Harris going all
Cloud Atlas on us but uh but yeah like I thought
that they tempered the history seen Cloud Atlas I
have not I just know you are speaking out of line
know that Asian face plot line had everybody uh
really really really appreciative must experience
context before declaring correct context I want
to see it uh but yeah I liked his presentence I
liked what he brought I liked the movie does do
that the way they just you know I get the choice
from the outside from the vague things I've heard
but maybe problematic you know maybe problematic
uh but yeah I like the way they updated the from
what I understand the little I know about the
original character from way back in you know the
the beginnings of Doctor Who I liked what they
updated him to here and yeah I I like that it was
something that is largely here in the present with
our major characters kind of reconnecting to
yeah here's our Ensemble commemorating all the
time that we have spent together especially with
unit bringing back old Companions and and we did
see Mel briefly at like the companion support
group at the end of the Whitaker season she's
not one of the ones that like I don't think is you
know like coming back and helping directly because
we had the other two uh but uh but yeah like all
those things were nice um and yeah I I if anything
I was just like man I could do with another like
15 minutes on this cuz the the third act like is
it's a it's Doctor Who so so the third Act is
truncated and it's a special it's longer than
a normal episode but it's still like 55 minutes
and I'm like ah man this is the time where you
could go for an hour 10 or something like that and
and you know I I bought most everything I do have
questions about stuff uh I like generally that
they're making some of these choices though just
because I mean yeah they're they're obviously
nodding to certain aspects of our culture
especially with the whole uh Motif they used of
uh the uh Toy uh Toy Maker you know creating this
game where everybody basically assumes that
they are just like of the utmost Authority
and everyone assumes that they're correct in
all of their opinions and that sort of boiling
over into chaos that's very relevant to our times
and whatnot how uh you know cuz uh I'm right and
I said so and you shouldn't question me when I'm
speaking cuz I know what I'm talking [Music] about
um yeah like I like all that stuff and I like that
you know in coming back to tenant with these three
episodes and Katherine Tate you know going back to
something lovely and familiar you're kind of able
to have your cake and eat it to because throughout
the tone and the themes they've been like no we
are not going to stop you know addressing the real
world and creating these you know uh they're not
like the most deeply veiled allegories but you
know like stuff that obviously has touchstones
to Modern Life we're not going to stop doing that
um and so I I I thought they were super subtle in
this episode they were the subtlest um but I do
I'm of two minds I I'm by generated now because
part of me and I know there was so much with
the Timeless child that people don't like uh
it's always hazardous when you're adding new
lore I I would be curious to go back and you
answering question terrain or criticism terrain uh
question terrain more than anything thing maybe I
don't have a direct criticism right now for the
the I do okay I don't okay just damn it have one
let's fight um yeah I I it's always I would if
anybody wants to comment and shouts out to Rosie
over at the patreon I'm sure you would be a great
you know person to put this list together for me
but like I'm curious to have an amalgamation
of all the things that the new series starting
at eckl and Beyond has added to the rules in the
can and I know that they recontextualized the 12
regenerations into a more unlimited thing uh and
now we have this by generation I appreciate that
they're not resting on the old lore I think that's
one piece of friction spot of friction that we run
into with all of these beloved properties now
is like you can only change the lore in certain
ways and and you know there's always going to
be a Grace with which you need to uh you know
proceed in order to do that um but I do appreciate
that they are you know not resting on you know the
old stuff and as much as we do have a lovely
boost of nostalgia in the circumstances here
it's also like no we're going to keep adding new
ideas to what the lore can be and how it can work
and so yeah I'm still chewing and processing
the the by generation chewy as a yeah we're
home uh as a concept uh But Here and Now like at
face value I like it you know like it's and that
whole thing about like I we thought this was a
myth you know like the idea exists or at least
we've acknowledged in this episode that the myth
exists um now we never have to say goodbye to any
doctor that's the fear and I mean that's there's
already reasons why you don't have to say goodbye
to any doctor because they can bring them all back
somehow but like now we can just have a big cinem
and I we get a new doctor every episode well and
I don't know what the context was but well and I
you know what though I part of me thought like
maybe we talked about this at one point I don't
know but like having a season where it's it's
like a new doctor every episode would be C do
it like The Daily Show trying to replace Trevor
Noah where they're like we don't know what to do
so let's just get everybody uh like I think that
would be fun but uh but yeah like it on the one
hand I could see it opening a door to like well
then you can just always do this you can just
have infinite doctors and and it's like the toy
maker says I could just do this forever and have
a meadow of you um and I haven't read too far
into it I don't know what the plans are I I've
heard Russell T Davies has aspirations to you know
expand out the reach of what this universe can be
and certainly sending tenant off like this I think
is is interesting because on the one hand it's a
really lovely bow on everything that he has done
if he never returned to the role after this which
I assume even if they didn't buy generate I assume
he would at least in a small way at some point
but uh in doing this I feel like you have a nice
resting point for him it's the lovely thing the
doctor's never able to do and with tenant we've
certainly confronted number of times where it's
like I'm not going to come in for dinner I'm going
to peace out I'm going to do the Irish goodbye and
now he gets to have that lovely sort of rest with
his you know chos that was the Easter egg yep when
he said when he said you're not going to leave
without saying goodbye yeah that was the Easter
egg yeah I tried to do that to Donna as [__]
it's messed up man no when when um 15 oh that's
right and he was going to do it's what you do man
yeah see and now and it's not going to do it now
and it's it's gross no man he's not going to do
it but also at the same time you're like well this
does also give you an ex a direct opening to have
just two series he's got a freaking Tardis of his
if they put him without his own tardis I'd be like
yeah the doctor's going to live ostensibly happily
ever after or 14 is uh but on the other hand I'm
like well you can kind of do what you want so
it's it's conscientious and that they don't have
to but they easily can um it's just a little I
guess my initial concern is it's a little it's
like an initial concern it all depends on how
they handled it moving forward M it's the way how
people complain about anything with like Marvel or
Star Wars like god let's let these characters
die you know and the doctor Never Dies he's
already Immortal yeah and I'm like part of me is a
little concerned of is this too Immortal now sure
I've already gotten on board with the immortality
like honestly Timeless child stuff did not really
bother John and I uh it it didn't really bother me
be because I think we just kind of watched it as
one binge yeah whereas everyone else kind of has
like I watch it and then I have a a little bit of
a breather and I just I digest it and absorb it
and especially for those who absorb classic who I
could understand I get what's not to love yeah I I
I can totally get that but for in the immediacy of
watching it I was I remember being like all right
interesting okay fine you're clearly a special of
some kind even amongst a special race such as
the time Lords yeah yeah yeah so I was like all
right whatever I'll I'll go on board yeah and I'm
kind of I'm kind of at of the same mind but I'm
also weirdly more con whereas like the Timeless
child I I think opened up I can't remember what
positive thing it opened up for me nor was I like
a negative about it you know yeah and here this at
least opens up positive doors MH and then it opens
up doors of concern of kind of emotionality weight
is is the is really the only thing right cuz it's
not really it doesn't really make a difference uh
you know because he still gets every new doctor
the 16th if it's a by generation instead of a
regeneration they would still get the memories of
1 through 15 that's the question actually is are
they going to do it so that and I've I've in the
vague I mean 15 has has everyone's memories 14 and
on 14 and before doesn't he I'm not sure well
I'm not sure it certainly would seem as though
but part of me wonders if in splitting them
apart and in restarting at series one again
because they've said they're doing that this
is a new series one with 15 but to cut you off
I thought to cut you off to cut you off what
to cut you off oh I was totally just talking
I had no idea you were even talking my days
have saying sorry to interrupt they done I'm
going to cut you off take it or leave it but I'm
talking now and I'll just turn your mic down if I
have sorry what were you gon to cut me
off oh I don't even remember now it's okay I just
wanted to make my joke it's okay it was about 15
we were talking about 15 the memories did I have
an actual point I don't know it sounded it sure
sounded like you did oh um I could think of one
what were we talking about we were talking about
whether or not 15 has all the memories of the
doctors which is a good question to ask oh to
cut you off yes and didn't they say with with
the ninth doctor wasn't that a series one yeah
that that's that is yeah exactly and that was
a reboot of some kind and I don't know I mean
ecken certainly as the doctor seem to have some
of the past traumas of being the doctor so I
don't really know what the reboot means in a
time where there hasn't been a massive break
to come back from um and I wonder if I don't
know it just makes me curious because what gets
divided in the by regenerating and what gets
changed it's like are they both 100% Time Lord
or is this something where like we had the thing
with tenant and Rose earlier where okay you have
like human doctor which I get the circumstances
were different for that and you know it's it's
just a human version that can grow old different
thing but at the same time it makes you wonder
like okay is tenant going to kind of carry on
the memories and maybe gotwa will be the kind
of a fresher slate than that maybe or maybe not
I don't know oh I think that's way too much if
they do that okay see that's the pro like you got
to think about if like the when the by generation
keeps happening like just the multiplication
process of that well I think the key is to not
do it much I think the the the thing is they've
set up a device that can work but that the that
you absolutely have to not get carried away with
and not use as an excuse just to have fun all the
time well I think that I think that's my question
is does okay when um 15th tenur is done then we
get to 16th is it a going to be a by gener I
mean we will we won't okay so you highly see
I was under the impression that that's how it's
going to be from here on out I think that's just
because this is a special with David Tenant I
think it's because of his legacy and of all the
new doctors he's easily the one everybody carals
around and agrees on the most I think if it was
just if you know in a scenario where it's just 50
or if it was just jod Whitaker regenerating on her
own and no special yeah I I don't think that would
happen so much cuz I don't think there's as much
of a reason to be like now I'm excited about
two doctors I've never met before versus now
I'm excited because one I love from before still
carries on okay that that's what was concerning
me about emotional weight because there's such
a there's such a thing to saying goodbye because
when as an audience member you are saying goodbye
to the the you're saying goodbye to the actor mhm
um and it it feels like you are leaving someone
behind as a character still yeah like when you
when Whitaker left or when Tennant first left
or whomever when Smith first left you feel like
you are saying goodbye e yeah you are you feel
like you are saying goodbye to this character
still yeah even though the doctor will carry
on you still feel like you're saying goodbye
to this person and meeting someone new and I
don't have that feeling now with with tenant
yeah it's like oh well I could probably see
him again and now we're just going to focus
our attention on someone else and that feeling of
saying goodbye is something that I hold kind of
dear to the Doctor Who experience yeah of kind
of putting some sense even though it's like I
know they can come back in some special or uh
they can do something right like you know yeah
there's there is a sense of he's just out there
of of something that feels a little more finite
when for a character who is infinite you know yeah
um and and I I treasure that feeling and I think
that's an important feeling to maintain agree and
that's the concern about the by generation 100%
100% oh you know like I don't really I don't know
how people might read into it as something else
as a result of like the non-binary stuff that was
uh you know upsetting the world um and and people
tweet about it those folks will stop existing
I will say I think Russ I think and I will say
like Russell T Davies is writing uh particularly
in the first and third episode when it comes to
uh certain political statements he wants to
let you know oh yeah he's like right wigers
you listening to my thoughts my little antix riff
here's my Twitter riff yeah yeah totally he does
get very very aggressive to the pointone where I
I'm aware that you are now writing a message like
I know that you want to rile up a certain group
of people right now I I completely get the the
sentiment of like I like it because it's just so
freaking it's so bold it's so on the nose it's so
on the nose but it seems clear that that's what it
wants to do it's so confidently on the nose that
I don't mind it where I'm like if it's one thing
if when you think you're being subtle but you're
not that's when that's when it annoys me you know
again I liken it to Barbie of of like Barbie's so
on the nose I'm like that's that's what it's
about that's what they're doing you know and
and that's what I feel like I'm watching her with
Doctor Who was like yeah I see what you're doing
because you're making it clear like yeah if we're
going to do it might as well not be might as well
go a little ham fist about it yeah um so yeah uh
I I will give it that and and that's my concern
with the by generation and my other question
is is um okay so when it comes to the face
yeah I do think that if eckleson was willing to
come back they would have brought back ecken I
I weirdly feel like for the arc they set forward
sure although you know it's like you would need it
for Rose I mean uh Donna you would need it for
Donna yeah rose already has her by um yeah but
man whatever the hell happened with Eon just get
like little nuggets that keep coming out um but
I'm like oh no that real run is done when you when
you get that yeah when you get the e that's when
that's when it's really done because even though
he's done I I think he's in like audio books or
something I some audio appearances uh is it not
audio books but some something yeah some weird
audio radio stories or yeah whatever whatever an
audio play becomes in the modern time yeah I think
he's done some yeah when when that that to me
would really feel like the that is the end of the
doctor of that run that would be a big surprise
yeah because because part of me is sitting here
going okay when are we going to get uh Mass Smith
back at some point for a special occasion when are
we going to get Kabal back at some point for a
special occasion and he's older certainly uh so
you know we got less time for that and but yeah
yeah like with eckl there's that back and forth
of like you know that there's certain friction it
doesn't seem like he's always the easiest person
to to work with on these things I've heard him
say that there was some conduct on set he wasn't
a fan of and I've also heard yeah oh eckelson
is yeah he's he's uh he didn't like the little
things have come out and you can kind of just
piece it all together over because he like he
likes to like reveal a little bit at a time but
yeah he didn't get along with that all with the
crew and I think him and him he wanted to work see
Davies again and I think that when it came time
for Doctor hoop time yeah uh they were not getting
along and then there was the other director too
he wasn't getting along with because I think in
recent years he has kind of recanted a bit and
been like oh I didn't realize exactly the mantle
in the time that I was stepping into the mantle
I didn't realize you know kind of what that would
mean and and what it would mean to people and and
just how a different side of of this apparatus
operates in terms of the and and the love and
all that stuff and so like part of me does hold
out hope that maybe someday he could come back and
yeah in a way he said he said he would come back
if it was like a solo thing he doesn't want to
do a crossover okay I I can I from what from the
amount I know about Christopher eckleson I could
see that it's like he would probably want to come
back for for some kind of special that he gets to
do the heavy lifting for and that like isn't oh be
a fun like few minutes of screen time with a bunch
of other doctors I I got to imagine yeah he he was
to really show up and act which I'm happy with I
like his doctor a lot but I also yeah like it it
to end the era and to reset the era it would feel
the fullest Circle and I guess it's just lucky
that everyone loves tenant so much because that
works too but yeah I get what you mean it's like
well I like tenant more certainly I can't disagree
I I as we have gone on like because I I really
like Christopher Eckles and I have a soft spot in
my heart for that doct you know as being my first
but uh but yeah I mean I'm not going to say that
he's the best one of the new series necessarily
because I don't think he was around long enough
to really like hit that full-on stride man you
know like sure yeah yeah I like what he did a lot
I like the flavors of his doctor but like you get
to tenant and you're just like wow there's just so
much more time to spread out and really embody and
inhabit this and then Smith and Capaldi and blah
blah blah they just all feel like they lead into
each other a bit more naturally than eckleson into
any of the rest of them well well okay so the
tenic comes back because what was the reasoning
do you remember well that something about showing
me something something I got so caught up in the
by generation thing that I'm like nothing else
matters to me right now I need to understand
this by generation thing it was one of those
emot I I like that this season or this Trio of
specials has also had those emotional beats where
Donna implies here that it's like and she says
it and 15 also says it it's uh it's like you're
you're running ragged you know like you're you're
stretching thin and you're exhausted and maybe
this is some sort of attempt to like uh return
to something warm and familiar and to find an old
friend and in that way it's it's funny cuz yeah
it's like if you had eckl for this these specials
or at least this special and you have Rose that
makes sense because they are such an iconic duo in
a lot of ways but I think yeah like do and Donna
also makes beautiful sense I think they like there
are a lot of great Companions and you can talk all
day about who's great and why and you know why
this might have worked with Martha or somebody
else but I think yeah like Katherine Tate being
back with tenant is such a lovely dynamic they
are a great set of characters and I I think it's
yeah it's that emotional thing of like instead
of it being some kind of Grand trick or a master
plan or a toy maker plan it's maybe it's just some
subconscious cry to you know get back to something
warm and familiar some kind of uh love support Etc
and maybe actually take a load off and rest after
all this well yeah it seems like the the only way
he could have had the opportunity to slow down and
Netflix and chill and have a home of any kind at
all it wouldn't be with any other compan Canon it
would be maybe with Mel cuz she's probably living
in an old folks home with her $60,000 she's got
the support group she's got the Y support group
oh yes yeah yeah she I I didn't catch it at first
but yeah she shows up in the support group at the
end there of the Whit her run Mel yeah she's not
one of the the main focus like there are a couple
other companions one's called Tegan I forget the
other one's name yeah they like yeah not one of
the two that's like on the adventure but she's
there at the end in that like Roundup of companion
cameos I like how they made justifications for why
he was an old man when he was kaliy sure they did
not make justifications for why he was a young hot
professor at a college University when he was Matt
Smith yeah you know he's like I'm just I'm younger
baby about cool and now season one new season one
we're just going to spend all this time being
like I decid to be black you can choose that's
why I chose a black face I chose to be a black
open up some weird racial implications they pick
they really pick and choose when they decided make
make something about the identity of appearance I
me I think there's fun to I don't recall anything
about like that's why I came as a woman yeah I
don't recall anything about that were just rolling
with it there's little cuse in culture currently
to be like why did I generate as a 30s something's
white guy you know whereas like if it's a woman or
if it's any other ethnicity or whatever it's out
of the ordinary well I can't wait to see 15 go to
like time periods as a black doctor that where
it would be really hard to just kind of oh yeah
everyone's going to be racist all the time all the
stuff Ryan companion dealt with when they would go
to certain eras yeah or Martha yeah mhm or other
black characters who would travel with Doctor sure
sure I mean he's going to have to experience
that now yeah and I mean it'll be interesting
to see how it manifests when it's the doctor and
not like an alien race or some or when there's a
white savior to save their black companion yeah
you got your white card Black savior yeah saving
himself sure being free of all the the bigotry all
the concern of other people's narrow-mindedness
but it would be really interesting for Russell T
Davies to write an episode similar to the Capaldi
episode when he's like why did I choose this old
face yes why for get so CAU why did I choose this
black knowing that Russell T D why did I choose
this blackface a and then Russell T there you
can make a lot of commentary man but maybe you
shouldn't do this maybe you should let a black
riter handle this episode or you know just like
let not talk about it yeah I mean yeah like that's
always an interesting facet and it makes me wonder
again like how much of that how self-reflexive
they're going to do uh go with the new iteration
or not because that's I feel like that's always
a part of it too is like every doctor has some
kind of torture but you know some of them are
more self-reflective than others yeah but as an
episode as a whole it was really fun M you know
um and I do I do agree I think it should have been
a little bit longer cuz like by the time it got
to like oh he's going to regenerate like I was
about to be like what this [__] just came out
of nowhere what the [__] and I like the game of
catch but it is a a bit like oh oh and we're done
oh it just you threw the thing and he didn't catch
it and we're done oh okay interesting yeah yeah
yeah so I I did think that it was like okay now
we're moving along like we're moving through some
like really quick like the beats that you must go
through through for your regeneration and or or
Now by Generation episode like you you you must go
through those beats but admittedly I was like this
is this is happening kind of I didn't really feel
like we built to this moment at all this feels
like a transition into something a bigger finale
or something yeah I I think I think one thing too
when it comes to regenerations or by Generations
is uh or any kind of you know new introduction uh
one thing I will hold dear is you kind of have to
make the episode sort of feel like it's sort of
about that or really building up to it in some way
yeah you know even if it's not like the whole time
they're just fighting against it you there's got
to be some type of inkling of we are on our way
to a goodbye yeah and I think that would have
sell the by generation moment even better if
it was like oh we're building up oh we're going
to say I have to say goodbye to tenant one more
time a this is going to be hard hard oh here what
not just oh my God is it already happening yeah
and then also on top of it's already happening
now there's like a whole new wrinkle of lore and
it's double happening what's happening yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I think that's why they I mean
even though the tenant thing was spoiled for us
that was impossible when it came from Whitaker to
tenant um that whole even that episode I I think
that's why the impact was beyond just being tenant
coming back I think that was another reason with
the with the big impact was all right let's see
what the new doctors after building up to it
in this episode knowing it's the final episode
um for now yeah but damn man dude and apparently
I didn't know this I like Whit girl a lot I wish
w I wish she would get more love I thought she
was great I I would and I would be really excited
for whatever crossover event brings her back at
some point I think they should absolutely bring
her back at some point really did she really took
care of my mommy issues for me I felt like she was
comforting me and giving me the nurturing I didn't
receive growing she was hey respect Jody Whit was
terrific in the role I know and I also thought she
was very physically attractive so it really played
on the Ed I thought she was terrific in the role
really did play my the hottest doct uh one thing I
learned which I didn't realize is that uh part
of what enticed Russell T Davy's back to this
world was uh you know our reactions on patreon a
stream events yeah actually there was like a big
stream along event that somebody was doing during
the pandemic that got like Steven Moffet back on
Twitter and then Russell T Davies was like damn I
got to check this out too and like man everyone's
tuning in at the same time and doing this live
watch watch this [__] people watch this [__]
and they do it together online what what this is
this is this is these just we were just making
these for us all right well time to get some
uh left agendas out there yeah that's what the
internet loves yeah yeah so you know stream alongs
watch alongs we we we we got Doctor Who we save we
saved Doctor Who or something I don't know I mean
I like yeah I don't think Doctor Who really needed
to be saved but it needed to be saved from some
tonal issues but other than that but but yes in
closing as long as they don't I'll be happy with
this stuff if they don't buy generate all the time
and if we don't see tenant for a while is is kind
of I wonder I think every other episode should be
tenant well part of me wonders if they're going
to use him as like a as like a resource like ah
[__] we we've run into a a conundrum let's stop
by you know chisik and ask David tennis and then
like even with like the second Tardis I'm like
what some you know there's just some stuff oh and
the master and he's in the gold tooth that's right
master in the gold tooth and who grabbed the tooth
oh dude that was uh I think it was um was it Kate
would it be K would you pull a maneuver like that
maybe to well it's certainly seem like a sneaky
thing not like we got to keep this tooth under
lock and key we got to go through everyone's hands
and see the nail polish yeah and be detectives
yeah or we just wait for some other editor on
YouTube to figure out like it's definitely this
hand if you look at this other [__] from this
episode and that episode oh cool good to know
Masters and we did see it dude and then we got
Christmas in a couple of weeks excited to see
uh yeah I'm excited to spend Christmas with you I
am excited to come here Christmas you'll be here
day Christmas Day right I will be here Chas edit
and and then you can edit it all day and I'll sit
across the room and be like you're doing great now
you're killing the game right now they be like no
you can't go back to your family we have you have
to keep me company while I work on do your gift
to me is to be here for the next 5 to8 hours while
I edit and thumbnail and upload and assemble this
for the people it's red nail polish on those
fingers who was wearing red Mel had red hair
maybe she took oh my God is it is the is uh the
paraplegic woman oh that's right she rolled over
there maybe no one saw yeah no one would suspect
me I'm in a wheelchair well she can get out of
the wheelchair here in there so maybe it could
be I'm like who else had red nail polish damn no
I don't know it can't be Donna Donna becomes the
new master master Donna dude is that who I think
it is no it's random number damn it spam spam
call sorry yeah all right well I'm going to be
scrubbing for the next few hours for red nail
polish and last nope ready to go home now yeah
well get out of here was a good episode liked it
a lot it a great series of specials I can't wait
to cosplay as 15 dude you just fear my underw get
I would be overjoyed if that's his outfit I think
for the Christmas special he should just be we
should just wear we should just wear tidy Whitey
and white button downs and then we'll double down
and do blackface yes I think we should it'll be
like hey if the doctor can regenerate why can't
we yeah why can't we choose our face I'll be the
new Rachel dozol baby I'm taking the right lessons
aren't I yeah this is yeah this is the woke agenda
they wanted to inspire in us right yeah you should
do it I mean I'm down for the underwear bit I'm
down for the underwear bit bit if P we might be
able to just keep it going for all the 2024 I'll
have to do some squats in the meantime all right
well if you made it this far hopefully uh I don't
know when we'll get that Christmas specialty
you guys that'll be a while it'll be February
2021 I might just might just catch up like right
before the new season comes out somewhere between
Christmas maybe the I I need I'm going to want a
little bit of a break take a load off if anyone
on Earth deserves a few days off for the holidays
it is it's Ryan it's Ryan Ary you don't do [__]
yeah I don't do anything man I'm nothing um Al
righty guys well thank you so much for being
here um make sure to buy yourself a timey WBY
whatever I called that shirt wly wobbly timey
wiy the doled it and I can't remember what it's
called yeah you gave it the longest title for a
t-shirt ever cuz it should be it should be I think
it you the wibbly wobbly Tim timey Wy doctor had
Tardis quotes galif speak and I was like no let's
go wibbly wobbly doctor's lexicon quotes yeah man
it's good makes some super like verbose Whimsical
it's the shirt is bigger on the inside the name
of the shirt is big but you should see it on the
inside how trippy of a shirt would that be that
would be you put it on and you're like what so big
oh my God I take it off and it's just like a small
how every time put it on it fits like an extra
large and yet it's a size small hey this is great
for shoplifting just whoop whoop whoop they should
bring back James Cordon they should bring you know
one place excited to see him one time people like
James Gordon Dr cuz it's just the right amount
it's just the right pitch he's believable as that
character I never saw James I never saw like oh
I'm watching James Cordon I was always whoever
that guy is yeah I know slacker not a slack his
name again yeah but he's got the baby and yeah
yeah and the wife who never notices his absence
yes hey man now that we're back maybe tenant can
go see him you know sure maybe he can surprise
and be like hey I know you spent more time with
Matt Smith than me but hope people everyone who
encounters 14 now is like you're really boring
when we're not traveling you Just sh don't shut
up yeah we know you traveled oh take me oh you
won't take me you just want to like get fat yeah
you just want to sit here and eat and comment on
the molecular construction of all the foods that
we have on or Postmates all day you just want to
like break scientifically break down the regular
aspects of our life for the eenth time they should
that would be a fun episode if like he finally
decides to see him and tenis just like super fat
he's just a busy body and he's fat Don's like
we can't get him out of the house he won't stop
watching the TV yeah you do like the Classic Bits
where he's like he plays Xbox online in the Tardis
all day yeah oh my God yeah he's got just like a
mess of cables running into the Tardis door just
like a a pathway of discarded chip wrappers it's
hilarious that's oh it's a consistently hilarious
bit I do not use that word you take character make
them fat they play online G it's hilarious yeah
and they get overly invested in it every time yeah
and then he's like you know bitching out some kid
some po kid oh oh yeah and he's got to have like
a kid companion oh sure he's got like a kid got a
child teenage friend the neighbor friend yeah who
comments on like why is's the loser but the never
notices he's also a loser for hanging out with
this like older adult loser but he's a smart nerd
smart nerd child yeah and you finally it's funny
yeah I think it's hilarious it's always funny it's
always funny it's always hilarious and I hope they
do it I want to see Adam Sandler's Doctor Who it's
GNA be good is that what he does and that's my boy
no fine fine a hilarious movie way to go to and
I got to do some work okay my computer I'll stop
holding us up here guys leave a like let us know
what you thought of these specials and what you're
anticipating for the Christmas special are you a
fat gamer are you a fat gamer you fat gamer with a
beer you should be working comment below if you're
a fat gamer if you avoided your problems and
your Ambitions now you leave a hilarious life of
gaming being fat stereotypes and now you mom mom
my Mountain Dew my Mountain Dew mom get out of my
room bit get out of my room I'm on a campaign Mom
it's hilarious we're doing a raid right now fat
doctor oh yeah fat doctor fat doctor there should
be a that's the well that's the next Frontier is
we need like a body positive doctor no going to
watch a big that's James Cordon could be the body
positive doctor no one's going to watch it face
no one's going to watch it I will no one's going
to watch I will and then every episode is just
thinly veiled messaging about body positivity
that's that that's when these like rage bait
YouTube channels are going to be like can I can I
do thumbnails about this or will I just look like
I'm am I just going to look like a absolute bully
well cuz yeah that's where I start to to grow a
conscience of oh maybe I should is fat dreaming
oh damn which I mean you know people are happy to
do it's it's kind of sucks you know I feel like
people in totally watch an overweight doctor I
was totally kidding I I find that so relatable
I would watch an overweight doctor and I feel
like if anybody gets mad about it that's when the
bubble will burst cuz people are like you know we
all agree that women don't belong on TV or black
people but like there are fat people everywhere
like who cares unlike women and and black people
on [Laughter] bees all in my tummy Al on bees oh I
got you I got you it's the it's the Whimsy wibbly
wobbly timy wiy [Music] diabetes bees yeah and the
atap POS can come back and save the day oh for
sure dogs it's going to be good people love them
they got name checked here oh damn dude dude yeah
look I'm not going to I'm not going to say who but
there's a CH buddies with Cosmic wonder and he did
a video a few months ago and he's showing me about
how this other channel that has a few million Subs
where people have been calling them out for a lot
of plagiarism lately um how they did a video
with a very similar title and their thumbnail
is almost the exact same thing so so he's being
plagiarized can you guys guess which channel oh
God God put it in the comments oh God no who's
we're going to do a patron of the day shout out
yay take it away John what name we got hey
let's do the man Chris whama Chris Wham off
yes you know what you're getting for Christmas
this year you're getting a checkbook to write us
more money for our live streams that's right
our official live stream executive producer
every month you will you don't have to submit
it to streamlabs anymore we don't have to do a
live stream direct just put it in the tube tube
in the wallet it right to the go right to us I
already filled out all the information for you
all you got to do is sign it date it and boom
right to us yeah straight into the Wells Fargo
account we go uh no for for Christmas this year
you deserve a good one you should come to LA
and take a tour of the luxurious real reject
Studios yeah it'll be a great two be like a 20
minute visit yeah we'll really stretch out the
visit you this poster is from Star Wars this
poster is a Marvel poster this is an office
chair we got for free this is where we keep
the TV uh no you I hope this Christmas you
are able to enjoy your time with your fiance
cuz he is engaged to a hot Filipino woman oh
look out I know man that's right widen up
that bloodline of her yes dilute dilute to
Purity and sneak our our our white ancestry
right in there make it happen man that's
right that's how you get a Greg Elba hey damn you
whitewashed Filipino blood very very conflicting
you know personality traits Italians got that
are in that in between space where got Olive
SK all mean mean I mean I assume it's some kind
of Germanic like vhu that makes sense yeah well
he's very anti cliche Nazi German and he's back
quite the antithesis to it my friend it would
be a good cover though if you if you were an H but
Chris Wham off you are a sweetheart and I hope the
sweetest heart I hope I don't know if you believe
in Christmas but if you believe in all the good
that Christmas is supposed to be about anyway so
I think it cancels out you've been or Santa that's
for sure your Santa and Jesus all roll th% been
our Santa and our Jesus and our Godzilla all at
once all at once everything everywhere Atomic
breath of gifts is what we be like oh my God
it's go it's a gift yeah and he's destroyed the
city but it was worth it cuz it wasth cuz I got
a Walmart C we got some things we got some stuff
appreciate you love you Chris thank you for all
you've been doing for us and for being just the
ultimate support and uh in all seriousness I hope
that you are able to have a great Christmas with
your fiance yeah and whoever else matters in your
life no one else other than those people
Merry Christmas Merry [Music] Christmas